مع بدايه العد التنازلي لاجراء الاستحقاق
التشريعي الاول بعد الاجراءات الاستثنائيه
في تونس غابت كل المظاهر الانتخابيه او
تكاد ورغم ان الحمله الانتخابيه توشكو على
النهايه في الداخل فانها لم تشهد التنافس
المعهوده في الانتخابات السابقه اما
المواطنون فقد اختلفت ارائهم بين مساند
للمصار الانتخابيه ورافضا له
كلهم
جماعتها وخلتنا نحن في السفر خلت البلاد
فارغه
الانتخابات في الداخل والخارج وكانت اخر
خطواتها تامين وصول المواد الانتخابيه الى
مختلف في مراكز الاقتراع في الانتخابات
يؤك المتابعون انها ستشكل حجر الاساس في
طبيعه المشهد السياسيه التونسي مستقبلنا
قد تتغير نسبيا في الساعات القادمه
باعتبار الحماس التي قد تطفو للسطح جرار
عمل بعض المترشحين او هيئه الانتخابات
للتدريب همم لكن همم يبقى الرهان على هذا
الاستحقاق لتحقيق همم المحطه الاخيره في
مشروع رئيس قيس سعيد
على ان تتم عمليه التصويت على مدى ثلاثه
ايام في الخارج على ان يكون يوم التصويت
في الداخل في السابع عشر من شهر ديسمبر
كانون الاول
مع دخوله في مرحله الانتخابيه في الخارج
والحصار الانتخابات التشريعيه في ثلاث
دوائر فقط من اصل 10 تتواصل الحمله
الانتخابيه في الداخل باهته وقد غابت عنها
جل مظاهر تنافس في اول انتخابات تشريعيه
بعد اقرار الاجراءات الاستثنائيه في
البلاد وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس